[Music]
good morning Hank it's question Tuesday
the day that I answer real questions
from real nerdfighters let's get right
to it
would you rather have an elephant-sized
puppy or a puppy sized elephant well of
course I would rather have a puppy sized
elephant I mean I would rather have a
puppy sized elephant than a puppy sized
puppy imagine his little trunk and his
little elephant roar in fact I'm gonna
write a letter dear evolution I have
always believed in you and I have always
defended you now make me a puppy sized
elephant your friend John who would win
American Gladiators pirates or ninjas
okay on the one hand we have a bunch of
alcoholic pegleg smokers with scurvy and
then on the other hand we have perfectly
trained killing machines in excellent
physical condition so ninjas is hain't
gonna write any more songs I don't know
Hank you're gonna write any more songs
who the eff is Hank Hank is a spherical
mass of ice and rock visible from Earth
only with the telescope approximately
one-fifth the size of the Earth's moon
Hank was considered the ninth planet in
our solar system until recently when it
was announced that Hank is in fact just
something orbiting out there in the
distance what is the white book behind
you with a person on it it's The
Collected Poems of Federico Garcia Lorca
so how often are you doing videos now
once a week one of us will post at least
one video per week but on the other days
there will be fascinating pictures and
videos from other people in
nerdfighteria at the Ning
what's the Ning I've set it before and
I'll say it again link in the video info
when will your next book signing be it
looks like I'm going to be touring a lot
when Paper Towns comes out in September
I'll let you know what word you hate
saying and why I'm not very fond of the
word celebrity like I think the world
would be a better place if the word
celebrity and the idea behind it ceased
to exist would you rather be a gameboy a
Teletubby Harry Potter or George Lucas
well you only named one thing that's an
actual like living non imaginary human
being so obviously I'm gonna have to
pick Harry Potter
I mean game boys are inanimate
Teletubbies are imaginary and everybody
knows that episodes one through three
were written and directed by the robot
who killed George Lucas and invaded his
body what was the name of that Russian
ska song in the happy dance video I
swear to god I'm not making this up it
was called think who is your friend if
you put the narrator's from your two
books together mix them into a big pot
and then boiled out some fiction at the
bottom of that pot would you eventually
have your adolescent self kinda but
there are significant differences
between myself and the narrator's of my
novels like for instance in high school
I wasn't a very good student how's your
diet coming
along why are you bringing that up when
you know that it's not going well that
hurts my feelings are you still doing
weight watchers stop it that's mean does
writing about symbolism slash other
English stuff really help you become a
writer I mean I know reading and writing
is good but is writing about the 19th
century themes and Huck Finn all that
great you're not gonna like my answer
but yes English stuff really does help
you become a writer and Huck Finn is
actually an excellent example of this
there's a moment in Huck Finn when Huck
says of Tom he had a dream and it shot
him now that's a good line without
English stuff but with English stuff
you're able to look at that line in the
context of the American Civil War and
all of the other times in human history
when we've had dreams that shot us and
by writing about that you're able to
better see how good stories work which
is absolutely vital if you want to write
good stories of your own what's your
favorite type of pie definitely the kind
that helps us to calculate the
circumference of circles it's so helpful
and plus I never get tired of it because
it never repeats itself nerd jokes nerd
jokes nerd jokes a guy's washing windows
on a high-rise office building when he
slips and falls off a 60-foot ladder
onto the concrete sidewalk below
incredibly he doesn't injure himself in
any way how is that possible he didn't
fall off the top of the ladder he fell
off one of the bottom rungs hey riddle I
hope you like typos because you've just
been pwned
all time favorite song new partner by
the powers brothers cookie dough or cake
batter cookie dough which disease would
you most want to have um hyper awesome
tightest who's your favorite supermodel
frankly they're all tied for last place
when will the movie of your book Looking
for Alaska come out I don't know it's
not in my hands
where'd you buy your background bookcase
at a small family-owned neighborhood
furniture store called IKEA what is the
most useless piece of trivia you know
well I know that the famous political
philosopher Jean Jacques Rousseau really
really liked mooning people that's
pretty useless I mean both the knowledge
and the mooning Hank that's all the
questions I have time for I'll see you
next week